you look good on the outside the suit
looks fantastic I want to ask you about
this you have an underwear line yeah but
I want to ask you about aya got you have
not asked me to ask you about it I want
to ask you about it because you say that
this underwear changes people's lives it
does we'll see because the difference
that for men we a custom to getting
everything three in a pack all right
look at right there yeah a green shirt
you got three in the pack this is true
food yeah so now you know it's really
weird he's wearing all of them right now
Jenna's for women is different levels
right a woman you know like you go to
the Perla you go get different brands
out there
women can spend almost a limitless
amount of money they could buy you can
buy cards that are under clothes yeah
yeah it's not right for this was just
creating a higher tier like a a way to
treat yourself good okay
Oh a way for her to spend your money to
treat you good right okay tell me this
first of all let's look at the underwear
I want to get a look at this this is
called frigo crown there it is
that's frigo crown now tell us what's
going on first of all that's not what I
would look like if I were wearing frigo
crown exactly you Photoshop you to look
just like that do you if you have an
underwear that will Photoshop a new body
for me then yes this is not cheap this
underwear $125 125 dollars for underwear
pegye high-end high-end stuff
okay so way to treat yourself better and
I I don't want to be let's get into the
engineering of it what's going on up
front you see this has a special kind of
chamber right there's technology those
two straps on the side that's technology
yeah it's the pocket I would say
anything is technology we perspire most
where you rubbin yes so you start to
perspire down there you want to put
something in between everything so say
you freshen clean
built like a separate room for for a man
no he's in a separate chamber that that
goes into it deserves it deserves a
special space a special space are there
little magazines in there and stuff a
little drink sorry these are just things
I'm thinking about why is it called
crown what is crown crown you know I was
using the hierarchy of you know of
living for the theme of it and I suppose
the crown because well you putting the
crown jewels in it yeah yeah like a
vault
yeah very your vault all right listen
we're taking a quick break
I just I'm gonna get is there any chance
you could let me try a pair of this
underwear that's a lot of toupee
I don't mean us the ones you're wearing
I mean I'm just talking about if you and
me I would model a pair and and just try
it out to see if it works and then if it
works I'll send you back to them well
mr. Novoa
I send you boxes oh you send me some
because if I try them out and look if I
look good in these anybody who look good
you